recordemos a la entrada en vigencia
nuevas reglas para hacer el juego más
ágil más Dinámico reglas que han tenido
sus críticos pero que parecen haber dado
resultado como el tiempo límite entre el
lanzamientos las restricciones a las
formaciones defensivas o las bases más
grandes para incentivar el robo para
hacer la revisión de estas normas
saludamos en Caracas a Efraín zavarse
periodista especializado en béisbol
aprovechando esta pausa de la primera
mitad de la temporada de Efraín Muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros
Hola Omar Buenos días Espero estés bien
bien Efraín comenzamos haciendo el
análisis desde lo deportivo Qué impacto
han tenido estas nuevas disposiciones en
el desarrollo del juego digamos Cómo ha
sido el comportamiento de indicadores
Como por ejemplo los outs por violación
de estas normas
Pues bueno sí se han a ver el juego ha
cambiado creo que el objetivo se ha
cumplido mayor Lee béisbol buscaba
agilizar el juego darle mayor ritmo
reducir sobre todo el tiempo de los
encuentros en cuanto a promedio de nueve
innings que durante la temporada
anterior pues alcanzaron las tres horas
tres minutos en este momento estos
juegos duran tres dos horas treinta y
siete minutos por lo cual pues ha habido
una reducción importante con respecto a
a este asunto y es exactamente lo que
estaba buscando
medio béisbol a través de una serie de
reglas que pues han cambiado por
completo El ritmo de los juegos al menos
Durante los últimos 30 años
también se han limitado Efraín las
formaciones defensivas esas situaciones
en los que los jugadores de campo se
alineaban de acuerdo con el perfil del
bateador que estaba tomando el turno y y
donde representaba mayor peligro qué
evolución podemos hacer de la entrada en
vigencia de esta disposición
Pues bueno a ver con con respecto a esto
estaba buscando Major League Baseball
que
hubiesen más pelotas en juego y sobre
todo más corredores en base y hubiese
más acción
la aplicación de medidas sabermétricas
de nuevas estrategias basadas en los
aportes tecnológicos en el juego pues
aumentaron las formaciones especiales
defensivas sobre todo con respecto a los
bateadores
zurdos esto pues provocó que los
bateadores en vez de tratar simplemente
de hacer contacto para para poner la
pelota en juego simplemente buscarán
jonrones buscaran batazos largos lo que
a su vez tuvo como resultado un mayor
número de ponches y esto trajo como gran
consecuencia que
hubiese menos corredores en base de ese
menos acción en los compromisos ha
habido una reducción no significativa
pero reducción al fin con respecto al al
número de ponches o el promedio de
ponches por cada nueve INS y él averaje
de los bateadores ha aumentado con
respecto a la temporada anterior Ese
averaje fue de 243 el más bajo desde la
campaña de
1969 Por lo cual estas medidas sí han
tenido un resultado positivo pequeño en
este caso pero positivo en la dirección
que busca hemos visto Y ya hablando de
béisbol como deporte y no como deporte
sino más bien como espectáculo podemos
hablar de indicadores que nos muestran
el efecto de estas normas Cómo se han
comportado por ejemplo asistencia
duración de los partidos audiencia
televisiva que se puede decir en este
aspecto
bueno hemos visto como la audiencia
sobre todo en televisión que es
realmente el factor que más ayuda en
cuanto a las ganancias de Emely como
como industria como bien indicas como
espectáculo pues han aumentado durante
las últimas semanas la asistencia
también ha registrado en cuanto a
promedio Un aumento de alrededor de mil
aficionados por juego con respecto a la
campaña anterior y el promedio en cuanto
a la duración de los compromisos Pues
también se ha reducido
significativamente 27 minutos con
respecto a la campaña anterior y esto
era exactamente lo que está buscando
medio béisbol hay que recordar eumar que
esto es un negocio
medio las grandes ligas tienen 150 años
de historia y durante todo este lapso
Este es un espectáculo que ha
evolucionado porque se ha manejado bajo
el criterio de negocio por supuesto
negocio que tiene como base lo que
Honestamente se dirime sobre el terreno
de juego pero es un negocio al fin y
precisamente para preservar esta
condición pues melvi a partir de esta
campaña implementó estas nuevas normas
que de manera
positiva pues han dado resultados han
conseguido lo que emerelvi había estado
buscando